etet Alec Castonguay, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir!
OnOn va commencer avec les jeux
ololympiques. C'était entendu et
enenchanté le tic-tac de l'horle
àà Ottawa. On ne pouvait pas trp
tatarder. On va entendre Monsier
TrTrudeau.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU
prpremier ministre du Canadada
- - Nous sommes profondément
trtroublés par les violations
dedes droits de la personne
dudu gouvernement de la Chine.
C'C'est pourquoi nous annonçons
auaujourd'hui que nous n'allons
papas envoyer de représentants
didiplomatiques aux Jeux
ololympiques et paralympiques
dede Pékin cet hiver.
- - Avec l'histoire des de Michl
etet tout le reste, est-ce que e
n'n'était pas une évidence que
l'l'on devait suivre les
AmAméricains.
- - Ont passé plus de temps à
didiscuter de la nouvelle du jor
sisi on avait décidé le contrai.
EnEn rupture avec les États-Uni,
lala Grande-Bretagne et
l'l'Australie, la Nouvelle-
ZéZélande. Le Canada sur ce gene
dede dossier, pour des questions
dede taille de pays entre autre,
n'n'est pas à navant du défilé t
cece le cas encore du défilé. Iy
a a des gens qui vont dire de se
rarappeler Bryan Mulroney qui
avavait prie les devants sur le
poportail en Afrique du Sud. Mas
lala Chine, ce n'est pas l'Afrie
dudu Sud dans les relations
cocommerciales du Canada.
- - Ça aurait été étonnant
ququ'on soit les premiers en
liliste. Mais en même temps, à
papartir du moment où Washington
didit non, avec tous les démêlés
quque l'on a eus avec la Chine
dadans les dernières années, ce
seserait indécent de dire qu'onà
GaGali. C'était presque écrit ds
lele ciel. Dans un contexte de
COCOVID, est-ce que ça donne
ququelque chose? C'est un autre
dédébat.
- - C'est ce que j'allais
dedemander.
- - Les Chinois eux-mêmes disent
ququ'ils sont contents parce que
pepersonne va venir les savoir-
fafaire moins de circulation du
vivirus et on ne vous a pas évié
dede toute manière.
ReReste qu'il y a un message qui
esest passé quand même que mêmei
çaça ne change pas les choses du
jojour au lendemain, ne pas
acaccepter sans rien dire ce qui
sese passe avec les Ouïghours et
dédéjà un pas dans la bonne
didirection.
- - Il y a des gens qui disent e
leles chinois dans le fond vont
didire tant mieux que ça fait lr
afaffaire. Mais Guy Saint-Jacqus
fafait parti d'une haute école t
ilil dit que le président, ça
l'l'énerve. Il aurait voulu une
grgrande fête avec les dignitais
etet montrer que tous ces gens
ététaient à Pékin. Il n'est pas
cocontent ce soir.
- - C'est sûr qu'il n'est pas
cocontent. Après tout, pourquoin
dedemande des jeux olympiques
ququand on est un pays
tototalitaire, c'est pour montrr
ququ'on est un gros joueur sur a
scscène mondiale et que les auts
vovont venir quand même parce
ququ'ils doivent venir, les
atathlètes doivent être là. Sauf
ququ'on l'a dit, dans le contexe
dede la COVID, le boycott
amaméricain, actuellement, il ny
a a pas un diplomate américain i
a a le droit d'aller en Chine à
cacause de la COVID. C'était avt
lala décision. Ça ne fera pas ue
grgrosse différence. Mais il fat
momontrer de quelque façon un
dédésaccord y compris avec la
ququestion des de Michael. C'étt
évévident.
- - Est réglée. Vous allez dire
quque je suis logique, je vais
rerester dans le sport avant de
rereparler des CHSLD parce que
c'c'est loin d'être fini à Québ,
cece débat sur une éventuelle
enenquête. Baseball. Je vous fas
écécouter le chef de Québec
sosolidaire qui a posé une
ququestion à Monsieur Legault et
sasa réponse.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - J'aimerais qu'il soit très
clclair sur le fait que le plan,
cece n'est un stade à coût nul,
dodonc un investissement du
gogouvernement du Québec compené
papar des retombées économiques,
mamais qu'il y aura bel et bien
papas un seul sou d'argent publc
ininvesti dans le stade privé
dede Stephen Bronfman.
J'J'aimerais que ce soit clair
popour tout le monde.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Le chef de Québec solidaire
vava devoir trouver un autre sut
popour faire des sparages sur
seses comptes Twitter. Le chef
dede Québec solidaire nous dit
ququ'il veut faire de la nouvele
popolitique, qu'il veut faire ça
momoderne. Je n'ai jamais vu ça,
dede la bouette comme ça!
CoContrairement à ce que dit
lele chef de Québec solidaire,
sisi jamais il y a un stade de
babaseball, ça ne va pas coûtern
sosou aux contribuables québéco.
- - Il a dit une fois et il a
reredit par la suite, on ne meta
papas un sou dans cette affaire.
MiMichel, on parle du retour
évéventuel d'une équipe de base-
baballs professionnels à Montré,
unune demie équipe.
UnUn partage entre deux villes.
DéDéjà, c'est assez particulier.
QuQu'est-ce que vous comprenez?
C'C'est la fin du dossier?
- - Le ministre responsable du
reretour des expos, on a un
miministre responsable comme por
leles Nordiques, il a dit qu'il
n'n'aura pas d'aide directe. Ce
n'n'est pas exactement la même
chchose. Mais je comprends que e
gogouvernement de toute façon ne
sesert pas ce dossier très bien.
CeCe n'est pas certain que ça
fofonctionne la demie équipe
auaussi. Ça fait 20 ans que les
exexpos sont parties. C'est un
spsport qui est vieillissant, ls
fefemmes sont vieillissants. Jee
susuis pas certain que de toute
fafaçon, c'est une proposition i
titienne la route économiquemen.
AÀ moins de mettre des édifices
auautour du stade. Mais le terrn
esest très convoité aussi et ila
bebeaucoup de gens dont la
mamairesse qui vont vous dire
ququ'on peut faire autre chose.
- - Un stade qui servirait à 43
paparties, qui coûteraient 500
mimillions. Ce n'est pas évident
ququ'on va se précipiter pour
dodonner des fonds publics.
- - Est le principal problème du
gogouvernement parce que d'un
popoint de vue personnel, Françs
LeLegault est un amateur de bas-
baball. Il va plusieurs fois par
anannée à Boston. Il a une oreie
atattentive à ce type de projet
mamais il est tellement tout
crcroche, ce projet, la moitié
d'd'une équipe, c'est loin d'ête
seserti que le base-ball majeur
bobon vouloir. Est-ce que les
jojoueurs vont vouloir signer? l
n'n'y a personne qui va sentir n
atattachement à un retour à tems
papartiel. Ce n'est pas communié
àà temps plein avec un projet ax
alalentours du stade, qui pourrt
titirer la fibre quelconque qu'n
popourrait aller chercher. C'est
unun projet qui est un peu tout
crcroche et c'est beaucoup
d'd'argent et le gouvernement a
cecertainement d'autres priorit.
OnOn ne va pas se précipiter por
aiaider. Ça va prendre un très n
prprojet pour que le gouvernemet
etet de l'avant parce que
acactuellement, les conditions
popour reprendre les termes de
babase-ball ne sont pas gagnant.
- - Chantal?
- - Même un très bon projet,
lalaquelle n'a pas beaucoup
d'd'assise à Montréal et je suis
coconvaincu que si on sentait
ququ'il y a une grande
acacceptabilité sociale pour ce
prprojet, ou au moins un peu
d'd'enthousiasme, François Legat
pepeut-être obtiendrait un autre
didiscours mais le fait est qu'l
n'n'y a pas ce genre de sentimes
etet il n'aura probablement pase
gegenre de sentiments.s.
D'D'ailleurs, Monsieur Bronfmane
totourne vers Québec, il ne se
totourne pas vers ses amis du
paparti libéral fédéral à Ottawa
etet avec raison.
AÀ une époque, quand il y avait
dedes grands donateurs qui
fifinançaient les caisses des
paparties, des gens qui avaiente
gegenre de projet pouvaient avor
unun levier quelconque sur les
paparties au pouvoir mais on n't
plplus là.
OnOn ne s'en plaint pas.
MaMais il y a aussi que si les
momontréalais avaient élu Denis
CoCoderre, possiblement que le
gogouvernement de François Legat
seserait moins pressé de fermera
poporte. Mais dans ce cas-ci, le
vovote des montréalais aux
élélections municipales à n'est
papas nécessairement dans le ses
dudu retour du base-ball à
MoMontréal comme priorité.
- - Voilà, je le répète, Michel,
vovous êtes un amateur fini
etet ces 42 parties dont on par.
C'C'est la moitié d'une saison,
unune moitié équipe, une moitié
dadame parce que unique, on
l'l'aime, c'est vraiment bizarr.
- - Ça ne marche pas à la fin. a
gagarde partagée, c'est ce qu'on
fafait quand on divorce parce
ququ'on est obligé de le faire
mamais on ne fait pas ça pour ue
éqéquipe de balles. Ça ne marche
papas comme ça. Les jeunes femm,
ilils sont rendus ailleurs, pour
lele basket-ball par exemple. Le
babase-ball, c'est un sport de.e
nene suis pas sûr qu'il y a un
mamarché à Montréal pour un demi
clclub.
- - Peut-être pour les condos
auautour.
- - C'est une autre affaire.
- - Je m'avance, je m'arrête. Ls
CHCHSLD, on en parle à tous les
sosoirs. Les courriels qui ont é
mimis en preuve devant la coronr
hihier, on a refait un tour à
QuQuébec avec des demandes des
trtrois parties pour une enquête
pupublique. Et aujourd'hui,
l'l'opposition n'allait pas lâcr
lele morceau. On écoute et on
rerevient.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - Est-ce que le premier minise
ququi était le chef de la cellue
dede crise était le seul à ne ps
êêtre au courant qu'on allait
àà l'abattoir dans nos CHSLD?
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - On sait tous maintenant
ququ'il y a des établissements
ququi ont manqué d'équipement,
dodonc qu'il y a eu un problème
dede distribution.
MaMais ce qu'on avait à la tabl,
c'c'était l'inventaire national,
etet on essayait, même si
l'l'inventaire n'était pas
àà zéro, de tout faire en
nonotre possible. Donc, Monsieur
lele président, dès qu'on a eu
dede l'information, on a agi.
- - Alec, je vous repose presque
lala même question hier, mais ls
dedemandes de l'opposition ne
chchangeront pas. Ils vont rever
àà la charge et on a connu cela
dadans un autre parlement pour a
cocommission Gomery. On a connu
cecela à Québec pour la commissn
d'd'enquête sur la construction
etet les dons illégaux aux
paparties. Est-ce qu'on est dans
unun film qui ressemble à cela?n
esest dans un film différent por
dedeux raisons. D'abord, à
l'l'époque, quand vous parlez de
lala corruption ou la collusion
dadans l'industrie de la
coconstruction, c'était des
rérévélations des médias d'abord
etet avant tout. Les journalists
ququi alimentaient la controvere
etet on n'avait pas d'institutis
ququi se penchaient sur le
dodossier. Ça prenait un endroi.
CaCapable de colliger tout cela
esest allé plus loin avec des
obobligations de faire témoigner
dedes acteurs, d'aller chercher
dedes documents, avec plus de
momoyens que ce que les médias
avavaient. Les commissions
d'd'enquête publique sont nées.n
a a une enquête publique
prprésentement qui est celle dea
cocoroner parce que les documens
dodont on parle ont été déposé n
prpreuve lors de l'enquête
pupublique et on a trois autres
enenquêtes, celle de la
cocommissaire à la santé, la
vévérificatrice générale et on
nanacelles de la protectrice du
cicitoyen. Il y a déjà beaucoupe
momonde qui enquête là-dessus.Ça
enenlève un peu de poids à la
dedemande des parties
d'd'opposition. L'autre problèm,
c'c'est qu'il n'y a pas de figus
imimportantes extérieures à
l'l'Assemblée nationale
ququi demande cette enquête
pupublique. Dans le cas de Gome,
ilil y avait toutes sortes de gs
ququi disaient que ça n'avait
auaucun sens.
IlIl y avait des entrepreneurs i
s's'étaient faits louer qui
sosortaient. La protectrice du
cicitoyen a dit qu'elle a fait s
mamal de taux et il ne reste pls
bebeaucoup de pierres à retourn.
N'N'est pas certaine que c'est
nénécessaire. Vous avez Géhane
KaKamel qui dit qu'elle a encore
lele loisir de parvenir des
tétémoins.
- - Elle va aller du bout de ce
ququ'elle peut.
- - Si il y avait des médecins,
bebeaucoup d'associations
ququi le demandaient, il y aurat
plplus de traction pour les
paparties d'opposition qui
acactuellement sont un peu seuls
dadans leur coin. C'est limite
leleur capacité d'influencer le
gogouvernement.
- - La position de Monsieur
LeLegault à votre avis va
cecertainement pas changer compe
tetenu que les demandes ne
viviennent que de l'opposition.
- - À court terme, non.
- - Ça ne va pas changer car ila
ququand même.com entre la
cocommission Gomery et la
cocommission Charbonneau et ça a
papas très bien tourné pour le
gogouvernement qui a mis sur pid
ceces commissions. Alors pour
rarajouter à tout ce qui a été
didit, c'est totalement exact.
ReRegardez la position de la CAQ
dadans les intentions de vote. l
y y a peu de pressions
exextérieures. Si vous étiez un
gogouvernement, est-ce que vous
vovoudriez offrir un spectacle
tétélévisé à la veille d'une
cacampagne électorale en vue d'e
réréélection?
EÉcoutez, il en a déjà des
enenquêtes.
PoPoser la question, c'est y
rérépondre.
- - Monsieur Martin se souviente
cecette décision qu'il a prise,a
cocommission Gomery. Michiels?
- - Il n'y en aura pas d'enquête
popour les raisons que Chantal
dodonnait. Cela dit, ça ne veut
papas dire qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'd'une. Il y a quand même
dedes milliers de morts dans les
CHCHSLD. C'est une tragédie
nanationale. Mais il ne faut pas
unune commission d'enquête
trtraditionnelle où on cherche s
cocoupables mais une commission
d'd'enquête où les gens peuvent
vevenir témoigner et dire : voii
cece qu'on a fait, pas de croch,
mamais qu'on ne savait pas commt
sese préparer et voici ce qu'on
pepeut faire de mieux la prochae
fofois. Si on fait cela, c'est e
ququi va être utile.
MaMais en même temps, si on
s's'attend à une commission à la
GoGomery ou à la Charbonneau,
c'c'est clair que le gouvernemet
nene touchera pas à cela.
CÇa ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
fafaudrait pas faire quelque che
paparce que les enquêtes qui sot
enen cours sont quand même des
enenquêtes partielles avec le
popoint de vue très particulier.
LeLe coroner, ça cherche une
cecertaine chose et ça exclut un
cecertain nombre de choses.
- - On a hâte de lire cette
enenquête de Madame Kamel.
NéNéanmoins, avec les courriels
ququ'il a rendu public, notre
cocollègue hier, on a hâte de vr
sasa conclusion. Un dernier tour
dede table sur un sujet importat
etet c'est le Québec, une
cocommission qui va regrouper ts
leles partis à Québec, qui
rerecommande bel et bien d'élarr
l'l'aide médicale à mourir
popour les gens qui apprennent i
vovont souffrir d'Alzheimer, des
mamaladies dégénératives.
VoVous pourrez donc consentir,
ququand vous avez toute votre
ttête, avant de vous enfoncer, a
pepeut faire bouger les choses,n
totour de table, Michiels?
- - J'emploie trop souvent
l'l'expression que le diable est
dadans les détails. C'est bien e
coconsentir mais il y a quelqu'n
momoment donné qui va décider qe
jeje n'ai plus toute ma tête, je
didis que lorsque je vais être n
fafardeau, je veux qu'on me done
l'l'aide médicale à mourir. Il a
ququelqu'un qui va être obligé e
dédécider cela. Imaginez,
j'j'ai deux enfants, il y en a n
ququi dit oui et l'autre il dit
nonon. C'est ça qui risque de ne
papas marcher très bien. Il faut
vrvraiment voir les détails.
- - Les sondages, et je parle
papancanadien, ça manque c'est e
dedemande qui a l'appui d'une
mamajorité importante des
CaCanadiens, surtout dans les
trtranches plus vieilles. Le
gogouvernement fédéral dans la
dedernière mouture n'a pas pris
ininclut le consentement
ananticipé mais il a ordonné une
rérévision. C'est certain que ça
vava être un sujet qui va revenr
papas seulement à Québec mais à
OtOttawa aussi d'autant plus
ququ'au Sénat, aux dernières
nonouvelles, il y aurait une
mamajorité qui dirait qu'il faut
alaller dans ce sens. Et donc, e
n'n'ai pas l'impression qu'on va
écéchapper à ce débat et je n'ai
papas l'impression que les
gogouvernements vont pouvoir
ététernellement dire qu'on ne va
papas sur ce terrain.
- - On est plus dans comment y
ararriver que si on va y arrive.
C'C'est assez clair qu'il y a un
coconsensus autant des experts e
dedes parlementaires qui veulent
élélargir l'aide médicale à mour
popour les gens qui ont
l'l'Alzheimer et d'autres
mamaladi